saliendo victoriosa de las primarias del
martes en Wyoming harried hedman
agradeció en primer lugar a su mayor
partidario Donald Trump
su apoyo inquebrantable desde el
principio nos impulsó a la victoria esta
noche Wyoming ha hablado en nombre de
todos los que están preocupados porque
el juego está cada vez más amañado en su
contra durante su campaña gekkman hizo
eco y amplificó las afirmaciones del
expresidente sobre un presunto robo de
las elecciones presidenciales de 2020 en
un estado en el que el 70% de los votos
fueron para Trump en aquel entonces
hotman venció Ally de forma aplastante
poniendo fin a la candidatura de su
rival para un cuarto periodo en la
cámara de representantes al aceptar la
derrota Shiny que había presentado su
campaña como una lucha por el alma del
partido republicano aumentó sus críticas
al expresidente
[Aplausos]
debemos tener una visión muy clara de La
amenaza a la que nos enfrentamos Y de lo
que se necesita para derrotarla he dicho
desde el 6 de enero que haré lo que sea
necesario para garantizar que Donald
Trump no vuelva a estar cerca del
despacho oval y lo digo en serio
mientras Trump presidente Shiny votó En
consecuencia sus posturas republicanas
más del 90% de las veces pero después de
los disturbios del 6 de enero en el
Capitolio rompió con los miembros del
partido y se convirtió en una de sus más
firmes críticas sentándose como
vicepresidenta del panel del Congreso
que investigaba el asalto